Voici Maurice Druon,
le Secrétaire Perpétuel de l'Académie Française
à l'Institut de France.
Le voici magnifiquement vêtu d'un uniforme à 68 000 dollars,
approprié au rôle de l'Académie Française
qui est de légiférer
le bon usage du français
et de perpétuer la langue.
L'Académie Française a deux tâches principales :
elle compile un dictionnaire officiel du français -
la neuvième édition est en cours,
qui a commencé en 1930, et ils en sont à la lettre P.
Elle détermine également le bon usage,
comme par exemple le terme correct pour "email" en français,
qui devrait être "courriel".
On demande aux français d'appeler le World Wide Web
de la façon suivante :
la "toile d'araignée mondiale"
recommandations que les Français ignorent avec joie.
Il s'agit d'un modèle de définition du langage :
à savoir qu'il est légiféré par une académie.
Mais quiconque observe une langue réalise
que ceci est une vanité ridicule,
que la langue se dégage plutôt de l'interaction entre les esprits humains.
Et ceci peut être vu dans le changement inexorable du langage...
par le fait qu'au moment où l'Académie achève son dictionnaire,
il sera déjà largement dépassé.
On peut le voir dans
l'apparition constante de l'argot et des jargons,
dans les changements historiques des langues,
dans les divergences des dialectes
et dans la formation de nouvelles langues.
Le langage n'est pas tant un créateur de la nature humaine
qu'une fenêtre ouverte sur la nature humaine.
Dans le livre sur lequel je travaille,
j'espère utiliser le langage pour révéler
certains aspects de la nature humaine,
comme la machinerie cognitive
avec laquelle les humains conceptualisent le monde
et les relations qui régissent les interactions humaines.
Et je vais parler de ces deux aspects aujourd'hui.
Laissez-moi commencer avec un problème technique du langage
au sujet duquel je me suis inquiété quelque temps --
et j'espère que vous pardonnerez
ma passion pour les verbes et leurs utilisations.
Le problème est le suivant : quels verbes vont dans quelles constructions ?
Le verbe est le châssis de la phrase.
C'est le cadre autour duquel les autres parties sont verrouillées.
Voici un petit rappel
d'une chose que vous avez oubliée depuis longtemps.
Un verbe intransitif, comme "dîner", par exemple,
ne peut pas prendre d'objet direct.
Vous devez dire "Sam a dîné" et non "Sam a dîné la pizza".
Un verbe transitif ordonne
qu'il y ait un objet :
"Sam a dévoré la pizza". Vous ne pouvez pas dire "Sam a dévoré."
Il y a des dizaines de verbes dans ce genre,
et chacun construit sa phrase.
Le problème qui survient quand on explique comment les enfants apprennent une langue,
ou quand on apprend à des adultes pour qu'ils ne fassent pas de fautes grammaticales
ou lorsqu'on programme des ordinateurs pour utiliser le langage est :
quels verbes vont dans quelles constructions.
Par exemple, la construction du datif en anglais...
vous pouvez dire "Donner un muffin à une souris", datif prépositionnel,
ou bien "Lui donner un muffin", le datif à deux objets,
"Promettre quelque chose à quelqu'un", "Lui promettre quelque chose", etc.
Des centaines de verbes fonctionnent des deux manières.
On est tenté par la généralisation pour un enfant,
un adulte ou un ordinateur
de dire que tous les verbes qui apparaissent dans la construction,
"sujet-verbe-objet-à un destinataire"
peut aussi être utilisé comme "sujet-destinataire-verbe-objet".
C'est assez pratique,
car le langage est infini,
et vous ne pouvez pas répéter bêtement les phrases que vous avez entendues.
Vous devez synthétiser
de façon à créer et à comprendre de nouvelles phrases.
Ce serait là une manière de faire.
Malheureusement, des expressions idiosyncratiques existent.
Vous pouvez dire "Biff a amené la voiture à Chicago"
mais pas "Biff lui a amené la voiture".
Vous pouvez dire "Sal lui a donné un mal de tête",
mais c'est bizarre de dire "Sal a donné un mal de tête à Jason".
La solution est que ces constructions, malgré leur apparence,
ne sont pas synonymes.
Si vous regardez au microscope
la connaissance humaine, vous verrez qu'il y a une différence subtile
dans leur signification.
Donc, "Donner le X au Y"...
cette construction correspond à la pensée,
"Causer X d'aller à Y". Tandis que "Y donner le X"
correspond à la pensée "Causer Y d'avoir X"
De nombreux éléments peuvent être soumis à chaque construction,
un peu comme la figure classique des illusions renversées,
dans lesquelles vous pouvez soit vous concentrer
sur un objet particulier,
dans quel cas vous ne prêtez plus attention à l'espace autour,
ou vous pouvez voir les visages dans l'espace vide,
dans quel cas vous n'avez plus conscience de l'objet.
Comment ces constructions trouvent-elles écho dans le langage ?
Dans les deux cas, la chose qui est interprétée comme digne d'attention
constitue l'objet direct :
le nom après le verbe.
Donc quand vous pensez l'action comme causer le muffin à aller quelque part...
où vous faites quelque chose au muffin...
vous dites "Donner le muffin à la souris."
Quand vous le percevez comme "causer la souris à avoir quelque chose",
vous faites quelque chose à la souris,
donc vous l'exprimez comme "Lui donner le muffin".
Donc quels verbes vont dans quelles constructions....
Le problème avec lequel j'ai commencé...
dépend du sens du verbe : spécifier un mouvement
ou un changement de possession.
Donner quelque chose inclut à la fois causer quelque chose à partir
et causer quelqu'un à obtenir.
Emmener la voiture provoque un mouvement,
parce que Chicago ne peut pas posséder quelque chose.
Seuls les humains possèdent les choses.
Et donner mal à la tête à quelqu'un leur fait obtenir un mal de tête,
mais ce n'est pas comme si vous aviez pris le mal de tête de votre tête
pour le faire aller chez quelqu'un d'autre,
et faire en sorte qu'il arrive dans sa tête.
Vous ne serez que bruyant ou odieux,
ou d'une autre manière, leur causant un mal de tête.
Donc c'est
un exemple de chose que je fais dans mon boulot.
Mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'y intéresserait ?
Je pense qu'il y a un certain nombre de conclusions intéressantes,
à tirer de ça et d'autres analyses similaires
sur des centaines de verbes.
Premièrement, il y a un niveau de structure conceptuelle très subtile,
que nous prenons en compte automatiquement et inconsciemment,
à chaque fois que nous créons ou disons une phrase, ce qui gouverne notre utilisation du langage.
Vous pouvez appeler ça le langage de la pensée, ou le "Mentalien".
Il semble fondé sur une série fixe de concepts
qui gouvernent des douzaines de constructions et des milliers de verbes...
pas seulement en anglais mais dans toutes les autres langues...
des concepts fondamentaux comme l'espace,
le temps, la cause et l'intention...
comme : quels sont les moyens et quelle est la fin ?
Cela rappelle les types de catégories
qui selon Emmanuel Kant
sont le cadre fondateur de la pensée humaine,
et c'est intéressant de voir que notre utilisation inconsciente du langage
semble refléter ces catégories kantiennes...
Les qualités perceptibles n'ont aucune importance,
comme la couleur, la texture, le poids et la vitesse,
qui ne différencient presque jamais
l'utilisation des verbes dans des constructions différentes.
Un écueil supplémentaire est que toutes les constructions en anglais
ne sont pas utilisées seulement au sens propre,
mais de manière quasi-métaphorique.
Par exemple, cette construction, le datif,
n'est pas utilisé seulement pour transférer des choses,
mais aussi pour le transfert métaphorique des idées,
comme quand nous disons "Elle m'a raconté une histoire"
ou "me l'a racontée",
"Max enseigne l'espagnol aux étudiants" ou "leur enseigne l'espagnol".
C'est exactement la même construction,
mais il n'y a ni muffin, ni souris. Rien qui ne bouge.
On évoque ici la fonction de récipient de la communication,
dans laquelle nous concevons les idées comme des objets,
les phrases comme des récipients,
et la communication comme un genre d'envoi --
comme quand nous disons que nous "organisons" nos idées pour les "coucher sur" papier,
et si nos mots sont "vides" ou "creux",
nous pourrions faire passer ces idées "à" un auditeur
qui peut "déballer" nos mots pour en "extraire" le "contenu".
Ce genre de verbiage n'est pas l'exception, mais la règle.
C'est très difficile de trouver un exemple de langage abstrait
qui ne serait pas fondé sur une métaphore concrète.
Par exemple vous pouvez utiliser le verbe "aller"
et les prépositions "de" et "à"
dans un sens spatial littéral :
"Le messager est allé de Paris à Istanbul."
Vous pouvez aussi dire "Biff est passé d'un état malade à en bonne santé".
Biff n'a pas bougé. Il est peut-être resté au lit tout le temps,
mais c'est comme si sa santé est un point dans l'espace
que vous imaginez mouvante.
Ou "La réunion a duré de trois à quatre heures",
dans laquelle nous concevons le temps comme étiré le long d'une ligne.
De même, nous utilisons la force pour indiquer
pas seulement la force physique,
comme dans "Rose a forcé la porte pour l'ouvrir",
mais aussi comme force interpersonnelle,
comme dans "Rose a forcé Sadie à partir", pas nécessairement en la brusquant,
mais en la menaçant,
ou "Rose s'est forcée à partir",
comme s'il y avait deux entités en guerre
dans la tête de Rose.
La seconde conclusion est que l'abilité de concevoir
un élément de deux façons différentes,
comme "causer quelque chose à aller à quelqu'un",
et "causer quelqu'un à obtenir quelque chose",
je pense que c'est une caractéristique fondamentale de la pensée,
et c'est le fondement de l'argumentation humaine,
selon laquelle les gens ne diffèrent pas tant sur les faits
que sur la façon dont ils devraient être conçus.
Juste pour vous donner quelques exemples :
"mettre fin à une grossesse" contre "tuer un fœtus",
"une boule de cellules" contre "un enfant pas encore né",
"envahir l'Irak" contre "libérer l'Irak",
"redistribuer la richesse" contre "confisquer les gains".
Et je pense de manière générale
qu'il faut prendre au sérieux le fait
que la majorité de nos verbiages sur des éléments abstraits
est fondée sur des métaphores concrètes.
On verrait alors l'intelligence humaine elle-même
comme un répertoire de concepts -
comme les objets, l'espace, le temps, la cause et l'intention --
qui sont utiles dans une espèce sociale et érudite,
dont vous pouvez facilement imaginer l'évolution,
et le procédé d'abstraction métaphorique
qui nous permet de blanchir ces concepts
de leur contenu conceptuel d'origine -
l'espace, le temps et la force --
et de les appliquer à de nouveaux domaines abstraits,
donc de permettre à une espèce qui a évolué
depuis la manipulation des cailloux, des outils et des animaux
à la conceptualisation des mathématiques, de la physique et de la loi
et d'autres domaines abstraits.
Bon, j'avais dit que j'allais parler de deux perspectives sur la nature humaine:
la machinerie cognitive à travers laquelle nous conceptualisons le monde,
et maintenant je vais dire quelques mots sur les types de relations
qui régissent l'interaction sociale des hommes,
encore une fois, comme reflétée dans la langue.
Et je vais commencer avec une énigme: l'énigme de l'acte de discours indirect.
Je suis sûr que la plupart d'entre vous a vu le film "Fargo".
Vous vous souvenez peut-être de la scène où
le kidnapper est stoppé par un officier de police,
est demandé de montrer son permis de conduire,
et il sort son porte-feuille
avec un billet de 50 dollars
qui dépasse légèrement.
Et il dit, "Je me disais
que peut-être nous pourrions arranger cela ici à Fargo"--
ce que tout le monde, y compris l'audience,
interprète comme un pot-de-vin masqué.
Ce genre de discours indirect est courant dans la langue.
Par exemple, comme formules de politesse,
si quelqu'un dit, "Si vous pouviez passer la guacamole,
ça serait super,"
nous savons exactement ce qu'il veut dire,
même si c'est un concept assez bizarre
qui est exprimé.
(rires)
"Voudrais-tu venir faire un tour chez moi?"
Je pense que la plupart des gens
comprennent l'intention derrière cela.
Et de la même manière, si quelqu'un dit,
"Une belle boutique que tu as là, ça serait dommage s'il lui arrivait quelque chose" --
(rires)
nous comprenons cela comme une menace voilée,
plutôt que comme une cogitation de possibilités hypothétiques.
Alors l'énigme est, pourquoi les pots-de-vin,
les formules de politesse, les sollicitations et les menaces sont souvent masqués?
Personne n'est dupé --
les deux partis savent exactement ce que le locuteur veut dire,
et le locuteur sait que allocutaire sait
que le locuteur sait que l'allocutaire sait, etc etc.
Donc que se passe-t-il?
Je pense que l'idée principale est que la langue
est une façon de négocier les relations,
et les relations humaines tombent dans plusieurs catégories.
On a une taxonomie influente de l'anthropologue Alan Fiske,
selon laquelle les relations peuvent être catégorisées, plus ou moins,
en un fond commun, qui marche sur le principe de
"ce qui m'appartient t'appartient, et ce qui t'appartient m'appartient" --
le genre de mentalité qui opère au sein d'une famille, par exemple --
la dominance, dont le principe est "Ne me cherche pas,"
la réciprocité: "Rends-moi un service et je te renverrai l'ascenseur"
et la sexualité: dans les mots immortels de Cole Porter, "Faisons-le"
Les relations sont négociables.
Même si on a des situations par défaut
où une de ces mentalités peut être appliquée,
ces situations peuvent être étirées et étendues.
Par exemple, le fond commun s'applique le plus naturellement
au sein de la famille ou parmi les amis,
mais il peut être utilisé pour essayer de projeter
la mentalité de partager
avec des groupes qui ordinairement n'étaient pas disposés à l'utiliser --
par exemple, dans les confréries, les organisations fraternelles,
les sororités, les locutions comme, "l'homme de la famille,"
on essaie de faire des personnes non parentées
utiliser le type de relation qui normalement serait réservé
à la famille proche.
Mais les décalages -- quand une personne adopte un type de relation,
et l'autre en adopte un autre -- cela peut être bizarre.
Si vous vous servez une crevette
de l'assiette de votre patron,
par exemple, cela constituerait une situation gênante.
Ou si après le dîner un invité
sortait son porte-monnaie et vous proposait de payer pour le repas,
cela serait gênant aussi.
Dans des cas moins flagrants,
on a quand même une sorte de négociation qui se fait.
Au travail, par exemple,
on a toujours une tension sur le fait si l'employé
puisse socialiser avec le patron,
ou l'adresser
par son prénom.
Si deux amis ont une
transaction réciproque, comme la vente d'une voiture,
il est bien connu que ceci peut être une source
de tension ou de gêne.
En amour, la transition
de l'amitié au sexe
peut mener, de toute évidence, à différentes formes de gêne,
ainsi que le sexe au travail,
dans lequel cas on appelle le conflit
entre une relation sexuelle et de domination "harcèlement sexuel."
Alors, qu'est-ce que tout cela a à voir avec le langage?
Le langage, comme une interaction sociale,
doit satisfaire deux conditions.
On doit transmettre le véritable contenu --
nous revenons ici à la métaphore du récipient.
Vous voulez exprimer le pot-de-vin, la commande, la promesse,
la sollicitation etc --
mais vous devez aussi négocier
et maintenir le type de relation
que vous avez avec l'autre personne.
La solution, je pense, est d'utiliser le langage sur deux plans:
les signaux littéraux,
la relation la plus sûre avec l'allocutaire,
alors que le contenu impliqué --
la tâche de lire entre les lignes dont nous laissons le soin à l'allocutaire --
permet à l'allocutaire d'extraire l'interprétation
qui est la plus cohérente dans le contexte,
qui potentiellement initie une relation modifiée.
L'exemple le plus simple de cela est la formule de politesse.
Si vous exprimez votre requête comme une conditionnelle:
"Si vous pouviez ouvrir la fenêtre, ça serait super,"
même si le contenu est un impératif,
le fait que vous n'utilisez pas la tournure impérative
signifie que vous n'agissez pas comme si vous êtes dans une relation de domination,
où vous pouvez présupposer la soumission de l'autre.
D'un autre côté, si vous voulez ce fichu guacamole,
en exprimant votre requête comme une déclaration "si-alors",
vous pouvez faire passer le message
sans donner l'impression de commander l'autre.
Et d'une façon plus subtile, je pense, cela marche
pour tous les actes de parole dissimulés
impliquant une dénégation plausible:
les pots-de-vin, les menaces, les propositions,
les sollicitations etc.
Une façon de penser cela serait d'imaginer comment pourrait bien être la langue
si elle pouvait être utilisée que de façon littérale.
Et vous pouvez pensez cela en termes
d'une matrice de gain selon la théorie des jeux.
Mettez-vous à la place du kidnapper
voulant corrompre le policier.
Il y a un grand risque
dans les deux possibilités
d'avoir affaire à un policier honnête ou malhonnête.
Si vous n'offrez pas de pot-de-vin au policier,
alors vous aurez une contravention --
ou, comme c'est le cas dans "Fargo", pire --
que l'officier
soit honnête ou malhonnête:
qui ne tente rien n'a rien.
Dans ce cas, les conséquences sont assez graves.
D'un autre côté, si vous proposez le pot-de-vin,
si le policier est malhonnête,
alors vous gagnez le gros avantage de partir libre.
Si le policier est honnête, vous obtenez la grosse sanction
d'être arrêté pour corruption.
Donc ceci est une situation plutôt stressante.
D'un autre côté, avec le langage indirecte,
si vous émettez un pot-de-vin masqué,
alors le policier malhonnête
pourrait l'interpréter comme un pot-de-vin,
dans lequel cas vous gagnez la liberté,
le policier honnête ne pouvant vous retenir pour cause de corruption,
et alors, vous avez une ennuyeuse contravention.
Donc vous êtes tout le temps gagnants.
Et une analyse similaire, je pense,
pourrait s'appliquer à la gêne potentielle
d'une sollicitation sexuelle,
et dans les autres cas où la dénégation plausible est un atout.
Je pense que cela affirme
quelque chose dont les diplomates ont connaissance depuis longtemps --
c'est-à-dire, que l'imprécision de la langue,
loin d'être un défaut ou une imperfection,
peut en fait être une caractéristique du langage --
une caractéristique qu'on utilise à notre avantage dans les interactions sociales.
Donc pour résumer: la langue est une création humaine collective,
qui reflète la nature humaine --
comment nous conceptualisons la réalité,
comment nous nous rapportons l'un à l'autre --
et en analysant les différentes bizarreries et les complexités du langage,
je pense qu'on peut avoir une perspective sur ce qui nous motive.
Merci beaucoup.
(applaudissements)